[Music]
scotty mccreery has been tight-lipped
about his longtime love until now the
American Idol alum is spilling sweet
details about his relationship with
girlfriend Gabby who he met in
kindergarten
by the way in his new book go big or go
home you know we first started dating I
was 17 years old 18 years old and just
kind of been thrust into the limelight
and I told her I said look we can we can
call magazines and have a photo shoot or
we can just kind of keep it on the
down-low and we decided to keep it
low-key but we've been together four and
a half years now so I figured poundabout
did you kind of run everything by her as
you were writing it yeah I'm gonna read
the chapter and she's all gonna take
that out my mom's good so whatever she
asked fortunately the 22 year old also
speaks out about putting its foot down
and refusing to perform during a key
moment on Idol it's one of those things
we get on the show your life changes but
you as a person doesn't have to change
so I got dealt with the song I was
supposed to sing in a week and I wasn't
I loved the song with the background
behind it kind of made me a little iffy
and so I told him I didn't want to sing
it they said you don't have a choice
I've slept on it still don't want to
sing it so I told him I said no choice I
said what I'm not gonna not gonna show
up on stage this week so kind of forced
their hand a little bit
Scottie went on to win season 10 and is
now working on his third studio album
the album we're just about there we'll
still got a few more songs to cut so
hopefully soon
[Music]